the number to call is 617 830 for 750
let's start with name and where you're
calling from my name is jason and i'm
calling from dallas dallas texas all
right Jason in Texas what's on your mind
oh yeah I was just kind of wondering if
that's of course you've had a lot of
criticisms of Raza as long as other
things you might even hear me flip flop
on this question but for me I have kind
of a big flirt I thought this is
explicit in a liberal base when it comes
to the subject of Muslims I am of course
secular I believe they should have the
right to believe what they believe
everyone should be able to believe what
they want but the thing huh course well
a lot of mug they're doing a magician
I'm sorry to tell you you cut out just
for a second there and let's let's turn
Jason's volume up a little bit if we can
just repeat that last part there it
seems like a not sure of my last part
was that uh you know I'm for secularism
the protecting book day long has an
attack on circulating so whenever you
try and criticize Islam for being
against secularism he can be called a
bigot or in a wonderful uh attack from
the lab those kinda wondering is not on
that motive you know y le listen I mean
my thoughts on this report what my
thoughts are overarching and simple on
this which is uh anytime that there's
sort of an identity-based defense or
accusation of bias or discrimination we
should be skeptical of it and we should
really examine it at its merits right
and if if what you're pointing out
something that does exist which is it
attacks from Islam of uh of
non-believers as Islamophobic merely for
saying aye opposed any country where you
have some version of a religiously based
lon this might include making
abortion illegal in the US because
Christians don't like it or uh of
religious theocracies in the Middle East
based on Islam etcetera there's no doubt
that Islamophobia exists and is a
problem there's no doubt that Islamic
extremism existing is a problem and
there is no question whatsoever that
people who say hey I'm not picking on
any particular religion I am for
secularism total separation of church
and state uh and people from different
religions may attack that as
discriminatory I don't believe that it
is I think that if you if I look at any
country and I say I don't care what it
is that the dominant religion is there I
believe that the religion should not be
involved in any way in the day-to-day
affairs of individuals and in government
and in sort of civil law that is a very
clear idea logical statement that would
be unfair to interpret as being
discriminatory to any particular
religion I just think all you can really
do if you're on the receiving end of
that type of attack from Muslims or
Christians or Jews or whoever is to just
point out that what you insist that they
explain what about the idea is
discriminatory well I absolutely agree
with that um I'm wonder though um what
about some of the division is created
for example I think a lot about that
kind of argument that Bill Maher and Ben
Affleck had a while back that created a
lot of divisions yeah the side we've
talked about that I don't want to rehash
that entire thing now but I've talked
about this split that exists and we've
thrown around the term regressive left
authoritarian left etcetera etcetera i
mean iíve talked pretty extensively
about that i think the division is
completely unproductive but big picture
none of the fractures that have been
have been created to the extent that
they exist by this none of those groups
are going over to republicans by and
large so i think it's mostly an internal
issue that that hopefully progresses can
deal with head-on I I do have to move on
Jason I really appreciate the call from
Texas hope you call back again a very
very interesting and important issue